y'all i wish that people who
order uber eats or doordash understood
what it's like
to be a driver like i just spent 45
minutes
on a delivery and had to pay three
dollars to bring this person their food
because there was no parking
no free parking anywhere near their
building and they refused to come out
and meet me
they took me a dollar fifty and uber
paid me 250.
like i got a proof three times the rent
for income in two weeks and i can't
and it doesn't matter that i'm working
multiple jobs
it doesn't matter that i barely sleep
and can barely afford to feed myself i'm
about to be homeless for the third time
since may
and it's all because people don't trip
tip their delivery drivers
like how hard is it to throw us five
bucks he said something i thought was
interesting
he said the reason i'm about to be
homeless
is because people don't tip their
delivery drivers
but the reason why you're about to be
homeless
well let me rephrase one of the reasons
why
you're likely about to be homeless is
because a lot of companies get away with
not paying their
employees living wages whether it be
restaurants
or whether it be delivery services the
idea that it's on each
individual consumer to pay your living
wage
when your employer should is wild to me
is it maybe not the best thing that they
didn't tip you that much
i guess but if you've never asked
yourself why uber gets away with taking
such a large cut not only from the
restaurant
but from your your you the driver as
well it's easier for you to get
mad at an individual because that's a
face you can put on it
rather than a large company which is
faceless and locationless in a lot of
times a lot of times
so to me it seems like you're putting
your frustrations towards the wrong
places
rather than it being towards the right
places which is these
these huge companies who get away with
fleecing a lot of their employees
contractors what they prefer actually
not to pay them benefits
but those are my thoughts on that i
worked in the industry with the food and
beverage
industry and it's an industry where you
most of the times
wherever you are you have to tip the
people that's what is expected
as a patron for you to tip um the people
right on average it's 10 to 15
of your bill to tip the person and i
understand that that's how it works
that's how it's been working it's been
like that for ages you're a bartender
you can tip your bartender you go to the
restaurant you tip your server and stuff
like that
i had jobs where i had to be tipped it
was fun because you know
where i was working i was good i was
like what i was doing so i was making
tips and stuff like that
now i don't know about every places in
the world that require tips
okay but where i'm from where i've been
working with this
tips there's one thing that's a lot of
the workers
admit the tip is at your desk at the
the customer's discretion always they
push this thing where whenever
you know you have a service it's 10
that's the basic if you have good
service
it's 15 12 to 15 if you have great 50 as
a service
it's 18 and up but it is
at the discretion of the people and
sometimes it's really expected it's
expected they watch you the tip
they want you to you have to tip when
it's at the customer's discretion and
i've had people
ask for a tip even though the service
was poor but that's besides the point
one thing i would say about that is that
it's not because it's been like that for
ages
that it's right and that has to stay
like that i tip whenever i go out
i i'm not good i'm a good tipper i tip
when i go out
but if we go from for that basis of
tipping that's what i think
if we go for that basis of tipping it's
not just the server that should get a
tip yeah you know you split through all
the service but the person at the
kitchen should get a tip
everybody should get a tip right it's
not often
the place instead of requiring for a tip
and i know that there's some restaurants
that have been doing that
instead of for ex accepting a tip
increase the bill and know that there's
a portion that's going to
just increase the wage of all your
workers that's what i think
and that's from someone that worked in
the industry you know i mean
when you said it's because of people
like that that i'm gonna be homeless
i disagree just because yes you took a
job that
that has tips in them but because of
that you know that some you're gonna
have some good days
and you're gonna have some bad days you
cannot
necessarily rely on your tip for your
old livelihood
it's not possible you cannot just lean
on me and
just just decide that your tip is going
to take care of everything it's not
logical you're putting yourself in when
you're doing that if you have a good
tipping job
yes you do but now you're relying on
people that don't know and don't care
how much uber is charging you they think
you pay paid so they don't care
there's no information about that so
saying i had a problem and you could you
could rewind the video
when he said that i went i made i don't
know what i made but i made a face
it's because i'm like no you can't
solely rely on them and say
i'm gonna be homeless because of them
that's part of it but it's really
because of your choices maybe i'm harsh
maybe i'm very harsh
but again it's coming from someone that
worked in that industry i mean
it's a it's it's so many things you know
rent prices are increasing like crazy
yes and in the states specifically the
minimum wage is trash
for a lot of people are unskilled it's
hard to have labor and have a decent
rest you know
and then they won't pass this 15 minute
wait it's a whole a different story like
there's a plethora of things that are
leading towards the fact that you are
impoverished
but to put it on other individuals who
are not paying your bill it's like do we
pay
uh tips for mail delivery no
why because when you're buying and
you're paying for the service the
delivery driver is being paid a living
wage he's being well compensated so
there's no need for that kind of
transaction
you are doing the exact same job there
is zero difference
you are taking something and delivering
it to another location
the only difference is your employer
will not pay you properly
that is not my problem nor is it my
fault hike up all the prices but they
don't want to do that because they want
to make as much money
and they'll take advantage of you but
that's not my fault so if you think i'm
going to subsidize
your salary or if you think you can live
that way i'm sorry you got another thing
coming the tip thing
this thing is a problem yeah the tip
thing shouldn't be
i don't mind the tip thing right the way
i'm thinking
the tip is really an added thing
it's a plus on top of the base price
should be you should be good good with
your base price
and then the tip is extra now what they
do is that the government
even charge you on the tip so when you
don't tip
that's in in this province when when
someone doesn't tip
for example a server the server is
basically
paying for your drink apart is being
taxed for your drink
because the way the government works is
that they assume
that all the money that you made there's
ten percent a lease that you took on
tape
and there's good days there's bad days
right and maybe we need to change that
because the tip
is really just supposed to be an added
thing if your base
price is it's trash think twice about
that and they're such a [ __ ]
like what you only give good service if
you get tipped well that's nonsense
go to any other country where people
prepare food and they do all this stuff
even if you don't tip
they pay to wage so they still serve
well this idea what you think every
other job that doesn't have tips
involved that just has a wage they don't
have good customer service
you're not a special industry it's not
special you should be paid
a wage that is appropriate like everyone
else
and i think this whole system is stupid
coming from somebody who tips i have no
problem i do it because this is where i
live it's the environment whatever
you you abide by the customs of the area
it doesn't change the fact that the
system is [ __ ]
it is it is there's no way around it but
to think that
individuals are the reason why you're
not a man oh it's because they don't
want to pay you a wage
that's what it comes down to even if the
food price goes up i mean it's already
up for us
even if we didn't tip you if we're
tipping you it's probably going to be
the same price and if you just added the
tip into the
price of the food that's what it comes
down to everything is luxury like the
all those those
the uberese the door dash that's luxury
yeah that's luxury because
what but they charge more apps but
that's what i'm saying it's luxury right
because
you take your ass to the mcdonald's it's
not gonna here's the thing uber's eating
you know what you don't want to say that
because when they take a cut from the
restaurant and they're taking also a cut
from the driver yes right so they're
getting their cut
the problem is and that the driver is
completely ignored so do i think it's
fair no do i think it's right
no but it is what it is but you have to
take it to the right person you know so
listen i understand maybe why he would
have said those things because like when
you're facing homelessness yeah
it's emotions running high you're afraid
you've got a whole bunch of things going
on so
i don't wish that on you nor do i think
it's good and
i recognize things are tough but i think
placing your blame in the wrong places
doesn't help either
so i think there's a way to have
sympathy for what you're dealing with
and also
disagree with that sentiment we need to
change the system because even if
we choose to tip you today and tip you
tomorrow and all that stuff like
doesn't mean that you're going to be
good next month when right prices or
next year when rent prices go higher
what am i going to take you six dollars
how about seven dollars eight dollars
nine dollars ten dollars when does it
ever end
we have other societal issues that we
have to fix before we can get to stuff
you know so
that's my thoughts on that it's just
unfortunate and so i'm sorry for your
situation i hope it improves
[Music]
foreign